austin gomberg 27 year old entering his
third major league season he was
acquired in the nolan arenado deal there
were five players
four minor leaguers and then he walked
smokey bets to open the day
i'm sure some adrenaline going here
for gomber he's just trying to settle
down doing some walking around the
mountain you can tell he's fighting it a
little bit
pollock bounces one back to him the fly
ball pitcher gets a ground ball then
throws it into center
that's up to third and the dodgers at
the corners dumber had it
easy one six three double play instead
he threw it to the first base side of
second
well in the aftermath of the trade
probably have more pressure than anybody
else number one without question is is
goblin from the eighth pitch to turner
it's off speed it's in the dirt and the
bases are loaded
already a visit from steve foster it's
not what you dream about as a starting
pitcher to
put on a new uniform big trade coming
over and not be able to find the strike
zone and
cause the error and they're loaded up
with nobody out here in the first inning
for will smith
chase is here kicks away bets is charged
at home and he will score
gomber unable to catch the throw from
diaz might have been a close play had
that been cleaner
dodgers have been presented some gifts
early
the bases are getting loaded on the
third walk of this first inning issued
by gomber
struggling here in the opening frame
against the dodgers taylor takes ball
four and it's two nothing
four first inning walks in austin
gandrew's rockies debut
and not just his rocky's debut but
remember
this is the guy they got in return for
their franchise cornerstone their
superstar
nolan arnado he's always going to have
that attached to him
lux swings it's a high front ball the
right center field
the charlie brockton will settle up here
makes the catch
turner chugging for the play throw goes
to third it's a timing play
looks like the run did cross in time the
run counts
and so a sacrifice fly for gavin lotts
the dodgers get three runs here in the
first inning against gomber julio aureus
the last time of course we saw
him was on the mound clinching throwing
a strike
to william thomas when the dodgers in
that joyful moment
clinched the world series title he makes
his first start of the year for the
dodgers
ground ball to third turner was playing
even with the bag he cuts it off and
throws him out
garrett hampson in center field this
afternoon
strikeout with a high fastball two goal
trevor storey's been the rockies
most consistent hitter crack bat roller
to the hole it's short
gavin luck's first career start there
with a clean play and a strong arm to
finish a one two three first for julio
urias
a career-high five walks
for austin gomber in
ten batters faced bets goes throw to
second and he's gonna get
it great throw by diaz mckinstry stay
put
see that arm strength of elias and that
helps out
austin goffer quite a bit 0-2 on
pollock and he got it he went around
so gobber breaks off his best curveball
and he gets
out of the inning taken for ball four
the seventh walk in two and two thirds
the most that a rockies pitcher has
issued since tyler chatwood walked eight
dodgers in 2017.
sharp one hopper to owings at second he
has it throws to first
and gomber is able to strand a pair
has gone six up six down getting two
outs with the fastball getting two outs
with a slurve and getting two outs for
the change mcmahon leading off the third
and striking out in a high fast ball
seven up seven down three strikeouts
for urias back-to-back k's to open the
third this one with a changeout
julio laurias who has allowed one hit
has not walked anybody struck out four
swings and misses at a change-up strike
three
the fifth one for urias got him with a
change
strikeout number six for the six coming
on the change up
two gone in the fifth for the rockies
meanwhile they have just one base runner
the pitcher got a hit back in the third
inning julio rios otherwise
perfect jonathan dawson swings at the
first pitch
and he'll remain efficient that's
dancing around there trying to find it
does one pitch one out sam hilliard will
pinch him
pokes a ground ball to third turn her
down to a knee to get it he'll throw him
out
chris owings has two of those ground
ball outs one to third one to short
there's a swing and a drive towards
right center field betts on the run he's
going to have to play it off the fence
he'll fire it back in but chris owings
with a
solid opposite field double gets the
rockies second hit of the afternoon
they try and create some traffic against
urias it's been
tough sledding outside ball four
it's first and second two out trevor
story coming up
and he's a tying run at the plate this
is the first spot of trouble
for urias and the fly ball on the first
pitch to mookie betts
that will end the sixth inning with the
dodgers in front three nothing
thanks so much for that maria's out
there for the seven
trying to put this rockies offense down
in the seventh inning they've scored 10
of their 19 runs in this series in the
seventh blackman pops it up
to the left turner with room and foul
territory makes the catch
first down to the seventh 02.
got his bat on it bounce it to lux
running throw
for round number two for julio urias who
now
has gone a career long six and two
thirds
a pop fly center field
chris taylor for the first time in his
big
league career julio orios goes seven
full minis
will smith beginning of the eighth
dodgers three to nothing
smith corks one in the air down the line
if it's fair they've got one
fair ball home run the dodgers have a
four to nothing lead who had never gone
deeper than six
and a third is pitching into the eighth
inning here with a four nothing lead
sharply hit past mckinstry able to pick
it up but no throw
yeah that is going to do it for julio
urias best start of his career
seven plus innings at coors field no
runs against him
and again the rockies have two on with
two outs trying to make something happen
garrett hampson is driven to a left
center field that's going to get down
taylor able to cut it off it's a two-run
double
for garrett hampson and it's now a 4-2
dodger lead so now here's trevor story
once again
representing the potential tying run
nelson tries to get his way out of this
strikes him out with a high nelson gets
out of it
all-star closer with the brewers in 2017
first year dodger corey knebel on for
his first save opportunity with the
dodgers
it's up to diaz to keep the hopes alive
for the rockies start him with a curve
bounce to third there's turner
there's three of four for the dodgers to
open the season
after losing opening day they win three
straight
the finale by final the 4-2